de là son chien le début de la carrière
de journaliste de guila marchés liés à
cet homme maurice duplessis qui dirige
alors la province de québec d'une main
de fer depuis plusieurs années et qui
s'apprêtent à déclencher une nouvelle
campagne électorale celle de 1956 dit la
marche est entré quelques mois plus tôt
ou de voir un des très rares organes de
presse qui se montrent critiques face au
régime du premier ministre de l'époque
ça s'appelait la chance d'un journaliste
qui commence sa carrière c'est à dire
que dans l'ambiance du devoir qui était
un journal d'idées et un journal
d'opposition
du plessis comme en mai au duplessisme
comme système comme mentalité en 1958 le
devoir sous la plume de son
correspondant à québec pierre laporte
met au jour le scandale du gaz naturel
une histoire de délits d'initiés dont
aurait profité plusieurs ministres le
quotidien on voit guy la marche couvrir
la conférence de presse de maurice du
peace no 2 mai allaient se toucher 4 qui
a entendu mon nom et leur devoir au bout
puis enlever la main le droit dans le
cas du devois donc j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de lui serrer la main mais
c'est une vraie raconte pas ce que je
pense sorties de suède je suis resté à
l'intérieur puis doublé la police pour
me sortir de là ce seront ses seules 15
minutes de gloire dira-t-il lui qui
n'aimait pas la confusion des genres et
se méfié du vedettariat
oui bien pour toute la soirée encore
après un passage au quotidien la presse
de montréal qui la marche autre radio
canada d'abord à la télévision où il
participe à toutes les grandes émissions
comme ici lors de la soirée électorale
de l'élection fédérale de 1960
garde partagée
il sera également correspondant de la
télévision de radio canada aux états
unis et couvrira pendant les années 60
tout les luce des afro-américains
la radio cherche qu'à ce qu'en dit de
nouveau dans l'art qui dit la marche
aura touché à toutes les formes de
journalisme puisqu'il terminera sa
carrière la radio de radio canada où il
animera entre autres les mission c'est
la faute aux médias
à sa retraite il décide de travailler
pour le bloc québécois où il rencontre
la députée francine lalonde il deviendra
son conjoint et sera à ses côtés pendant
sa maladie qui finira par l'emporter ils
fonderont d'ailleurs ensemble
l'association québécoise pour le droit
de mourir dans la dignité elle fut pour
moi une force civilisation très forte
avant leur endroit
certains diront que j'en avais peut-être
plus besoin mais j'ai toujours été
content d'être avec elle et j'ai pas eu
d'autre même lorsque la maladie devenue
dit c'est la vie frédéric nicoloff radio
canada montréal